non sono io proprio sbagliato l'intro
devi fare
gianpi devi e il mio video è questo
sapete tutti quanti con significa questa
maglia significa voglia di giappone ma
il giappone non ci possiamo andare
perché però possiamo che essergli vicino
almeno con gli spot commerciali sono
curioso di vedere cosa ci cacciano fuori
stavolta ragazzi
eccolo un ninja col tubo di supermario
il testa va bene che dite a tutti che
tanto non ai buchi per gli occhi come
vede probabilmente ai sensori non lo so
non lo so e comunque questo attore
giapponese io lo vedo sempre lo vedo
sempre non sono neanche in sala uno dei
più famosi attori giapponesi che
esistano youtube nel 2006 tutti i latti
uguale vorrei che mi spiegate questa a
cosa serve ma facciamo che non le
facciamo le domandano avanti mete dei
commenti le vostre domande a ogni spot e
io mi occupero nino entrarle alle
aziende cooper a pubblicità di
immobiliare giapponese non c'entra una
sega con gatti prove ma che ci scasso no
però chimera è un'applicazione sulla
pesca
[Musica]
volano scarpe senza motivo
non era un applicazione sulla pesca c'è
qualcosa in mano inabilità cosa ti
aspetta o caracca però stare calmi juve
è soddisfatta della bibita
[Musica]
iniziamo c ovviamente non ha un senso
andiamo avanti ragazzi
poi mi sei mesi e ne sente basta
pubblicizzare di vite basta basta basta
robe da bere e basta sembra fisso
andiamo avanti così la bolletta di goku
versione era shampoo cadenza smi questo
non era bene però forse era meglio il
bere o nintendo switch
nome mario party ma dai penso che una
roma nuova e tanto fini non è nuovo non
è uno sport nuovo se mario kart intendo
switch a noi era la pubblicità nintendo
switch non c'entra niente mario cosa
stai facendo tu lì dietro perché hai
questi capelli perché parlo io di
capelli che non dovrei parlare credo che
sia più citare il family market qualcosa
mi suggerisce i baci ma questo tic toc
air è bravissimo diamo avanti ragazzi
note che ho
no no no no no casoli ma perché no vabbè
allora no no no ragazzi allora
ascoltatevi io non voglio vivere
abbastanza da vedere un cesso su una
motocicletta
l'altro è il cesto quello moderno con lo
spruzzino perché giappone è già concessi
con madonna sequestare la copertina del
video hard bellissimo più che spray per
il cesso mi è venuta voglia di comprare
motocicletta concesso incastrato però
non penso esistono però sarebbe
veramente figo pensa a cagare in strano
e meraviglioso
[Musica]
avrei un sacco di cose da dire ma forse
è meglio che non le dico andiamo avanti
ragazzi questo è tra questa e takeshi's
castle fango a manetta quest'età che ci
sta
[Musica]
il game of thrones giapponese cosa
parliamo
non capisco cosa può essere sarà
un'applicazione di just dance
non ho idea di cosa sia ap di
messaggistica vocali sweat cos'era ve lo
dico io limite con le mani c'è un
babbuino con uno smartphone
signore e signori macchinette
sì ma i migliori tesi calia decreto era
un'anima anno non era un'anima era un
gioco vabbè lasciamo perdere comunque
c'è un babbuino con uno smartphone
quindi valeva tutto tre moschettieri
erano delle macchine ma cosa ovviamente
le macchine della daihatsu che è
un'espressione prettamente toscana
madonna il follo del c'è minimarket
buono che buono il pollo l'effetto di
bard ci sta pure parlando io dopo la
quarantena mcdonald gente può essere
petit bateau oggi ragazzi e te quiero è
veramente buona quello del primato in
quel mio fegato crolla dopo due giorni
mai veramente piano credibile rassicuro
madonna con toure con quello del film mi
è venuta l'acquolina in bocca a chi fa
questo è giorgio ti dà ovviamente c'è il
formaggio nel cisa
[Musica]
la mary poppins giapponese fighissimo
kimi schenardi neonato me è una bibita
che questa basta vi basta bere basta per
e basta che palle fatto effetto l'altro
grazie del tecnico d'ufficio dal gruppo
perché era il tè ovviamente da
inghilterra crispi seguici meno male che
non è da bene almeno bello non fatevi
della persona che viene vista l'uscita
per favore alla madonna quando vuoi
portare la suocera è in vacanza
[Musica]
però sono geniali
non capisco niente già dai sono avanti
c'è dai cameraman piccante canto di
dolcificante perché quella roba che
cento anni sbagliata tirato i
sottotitoli era meglio non leggerli
non ho capito di cosa è fatto frammenti
elefanti cosa sto vedendo volta
era a mentre lo abbia capito della
nissin solita storia sarà certa non
eravamo marionette libero mini mini non
ho capito cosa sponsorizza sta roba però
su quaggiù ai squadra isole per essere
maglietta no no di vite porcu demonio
ogni volta che li rimetteva solo pvd
giappone stato birra birra rosa non ho
capito perché la vergo
ma perché rosa la filiera tra
stranissimo stato
super ma perché superdrive a quella era
la sa i ragazzi tra buona però sono
astemio credo semplicità del dottor hunt
e questa sono io dopo aver fatto la
doccia bellissimo va bene ne avanti
questi hanno bisogno del deodorante
malta pubblicitari un altro tutor ante a
noi l'ammorbidente accende termini
detersivo la bora le che se non usi
detersivo i senti con gli amici non per
ivo ha ovviamente c'è sempre a bucita
lady riversa studiosi giappone concorso
cristo non so lizzano amanita e madonna
quando ci siamo stati la cacciata che
non sa più già incrociato la ripete
sempre non so sono ripetitivo ma vi
giuro c'è un sacco di gente signoris
spero che vi sia piaciuto questo è
quello che vi perdete se non andati già
andati in giappone ma edizione andata
con rebelo sciascia un commento questo
sulla vostra migliore pubblicità per me
ovviamente nel cesso imbattibile penso
schiacciata campanellina prima della
giornata i suoi video e come sempre noi
ci vediamo al prossimo video e ragazzi
[Musica]